they're moving I wish we could move who
says we can't
oh wait stop
look exposed brick you see there's a
doggy door we don't have a dog yet
it takes a real can-do spirit to move
and I just don't see it in you - that's
certainly not what it looked like online
not everybody gets to me some people get
stuck I can't do this
I for one still live with my parents and
you have a clipboard
maybe that delivery guy was right why
did we think we could move you're gonna
believe a delivery guy that got your
order wrong for two years how do you
know that just keep your head up and
lift with your legs
wait sir my name's Phil but you can call
me coach I don't know how much help I'd
be but ii give it a shot well where are
you taking those boxes anyways Oh
nowhere let's do this blob steam he says
strong I used to be like that in my day
not like you
that's more like alright cut I think I'm
gettin it well it looks like my work
here is done we can't do this without
you
all you need is each other no and that
strong guy with the truck yeah yeah we
definitely need him
all right all we gotta do is call for TV
and Internet and we're all moved in
actually we're all set
really yeah oh I wish coach could be
here for this hey this is great
find Commodus I'm glad you got over that
cough Phil I think nothing of it